[Music]
hello and welcome to the lobby game
spots weekly video game chat show every
tuesday at 2pm pacific right here on
gamespot.com i say every tuesday 2 p.m
pacific we won't be here next week
because the electronic triple is
happening justin hey walt hey how's it
going not too bad good to have you back
on the set here oh i can't wait for e3 i
know tick tock we're like four days away
from getting on planes trains and
automobiles down sound actually no kevin
van ord's not here anymore so nobody's
taking a train
that's not right peter that's correct
danny
um the the call the verbal call of your
name is for our wonderful friends
listening in their podcast ear holes and
they're going to be listening for quite
a lot while today because we've got a
bunch of sections on uh we've also got a
bunch of interesting accents for them on
today's show as well because our uk and
australian colleagues are in are in the
office this week for a second
i hadn't prepared yeah
did you not listen last week when we all
talked about like christopher walken for
the first 10 minutes of the show yeah so
that's what that's what we want you to
do okay
um we're going to talk about microsoft
go talk about sony we're gonna talk
about richard almost dropping the camera
we're gonna talk about nintendo bethesda
ubisoft ea take two and activision uh on
today's show and all of the sort of
things we think are gonna be talked
about and then some rumor control
and actually before we jump into that
we've had a couple of rumors already
today get leaked or just appear on the
internet um i guess the the big one is
the the watch dogs two thing ign front
page takeover of their site neogaf
spotted it i mean if the internet were a
ship it would be just at the bottom of
the ocean at this point because it
sprung so many leaks
and yeah i'm in watch dogs too
after initially being like being
revealed right okay yeah so so watch
who's coming guys it's okay and now
here's the release date and it's set in
san francisco and here's some other
details oops we had that marketing thing
go out a little bit early what was the
the did you spot the release date do you
remember what it is november subscribe
i'll chuck it up in a second um and then
the other thing as well african-american
protagonist and then set in san
francisco it looks like as well golden
gate bridge in the background so that
sounds cool right sure it's a good spot
you have to have the face like like any
movie like you it wouldn't be san
francisco without the golden gate bridge
even though i think i've crossed it
maybe twice yeah my entire life yeah not
often do we need to just hang it in
sausalito um but yeah yeah kind of a
good fit considering you know this is
the tech hub of the world right like if
you watch dogs you know no no offense to
chicago but maybe he works a little bit
better here yeah i think but how are
they going to utilize that right is it
just dressing or i mean
they're going to go to google they're
going to go to facebook it's just going
to have this whole coalescence of
technology in the bay area can you hold
it in the state market
airbnb's you can stay at
i mean if they're if they're able to
like jump into the whole like you know
social strata and gentrification and all
that sort of stuff then like that would
be pretty cool i guess we'll find there
[Music]
pretty soon another one that leaked then
i guess pretty recently was it injustice
2 there's some sort of screenshot i
think
[Music]
i think batman facing off against the
flash and we've heard
inklings of this for a while it's not a
surprising thing the injustice comic
series has only recently come to an end
but
it's something that's kind of ripe for
the next iteration in that cycle
uh the date for watch dogs 2 is november
15th as well which is on a on a tuesday
so yeah there you go tuesday tuesday
tuesday maybe three days later for
europe okay let's jump into one of the
many sections that we have outlined
today first of all gentlemen microsoft
let's talk about microsoft uh they
always do their press conference it's
like first thing on the monday right in
the morning their traditional time yeah
so we have a bunch of software stuff
first of all though let's talk about the
hardware project helix peter what is
this a bunch of different consoles yeah
what do we think we're gonna see at e3
so if i remember correctly it's two
consoles one that should be coming out
sooner which is sort of like a
lightweight version of the xbox one like
a mini or something yeah and then a
more powerful version in 2017. that's
the rumor right scorpio is what they're
calling that one yeah so brandon which
they should keep like you shouldn't just
call it
xbox scorpio it's badass i mean i hope
that because we've got a bet on that if
it's called the xbox two i have to shave
my head right
if any iteration is called the xbox two
any iteration ever okay yeah that's fair
no no within the xbox one's life cycle
okay but if it's not i have to i mean if
they if they if you have your beard that
would be agreed upon i mean no i mean
that's right we did not agree upon that
we can do that right now that'll mark if
that happens that'll mark the second
time i've shaved my beard presumably it
will be on camera for
game spot for game spot yeah yeah you
did for extra life uh last year two
years ago i think it was yeah yeah you
babyfaced assassin uh yeah so xbox
scorpio the one uh looks like a sizeable
increase in power um over the original
xbox um or sorry over the xbox one now
i'm doing it and then there also was
sort of rumors of the xbox one like
streaming stick set-top box kind of let
me tell you what i think that is right
that is probably a way to let you cause
microsoft is always talking about
bringing xbox one and pc markets
together yes and let's be frank they're
not going to really
[Music]
do that wholeheartedly but a stick that
allows you to stream from your pc to
your tv branding at the xbox is a really
good way to kind of attach that brand to
pc gaming in a in a soft move yeah so
sort of like a chromecast kind of thing
you could imagine yeah yeah i mean that
was the whole point of the xbox in the
first place right now microsoft wanted
to get inside of the living room and
we've talked before about steam boxes
and that sort of weird battle that's
happening about pc trying to get in the
room in that room i mean microsoft
already owned the pc market essentially
gaming market and then they already are
in living rooms so it kind of makes a
good fit right maybe they can attack it
from that side and especially because
you don't need things like the the
connect to do this voice activated
connectivity that's something that's
just built into windows 10 you have
cortana and just bringing that to more
technologies you'd definitely be able to
do that with a streaming box and have
that same functionality that you get
with connect yeah interesting i mean i
feel like we've seen these things pop up
in various different iterations for the
past couple of years would it be weird
that microsoft might be the one to pull
it off or do you think they're a good
fit
they're a good fit to experiment in that
space because i think they need to
differentiate themselves right now uh
and i think if you ask most people in a
battle between microsoft and sony and
the traditional consoles that they have
currently available sony's kind of on
top yeah both in sales numbers and i
think even if you look at the track
record of games over the past year or
two is probably tracking higher than
them so if they were able to do this
move i think that would be the smart way
for them to say hey we're different
we're not just another one of these
trying to compete but they have to
announce a more powerful console as well
because if if they're going up against
playstation 4 headlines will just be
dominated with here's the ps 4.5 more
powerful bigger stronger and here's the
xbox less powerful kind of streaming
thing like they they need that mind
share of and we also have our bigger
beefier guy that you're going to write
they also need to talk about these
things because all of the discussions
that are happening all the hype around
this like the expectations yeah if this
is all wrong and they they actually
didn't have plans to talk about it yeah
don't say a peep
the internet's gonna be really upset
yeah and microsoft are very very gun shy
about making a bad impression at e3
because they've basically spent two or
three years trying to fix that you know
at this stage um yeah it's gonna be very
very interesting i mean an opportunity
for them to flip the script completely
if they come out with scorpio and it
ends up being much more powerful than a
4.5 like that would really make things
interesting um let's talk about software
though consoles are nothing without the
games they're getting played on them um
some of microsoft's i guess staples are
reappearing this year uh first of all
gears of war four we're hopefully gonna
see more of that do you guys impressed
by the demo at all that they showed last
year i remember thinking it was really
dark and i wasn't really into it at all
it's hard to tell what was going on i i
think remastered was well received it's
nice to go back to that world i'm
interested to see what they'll do with
gears of war four now like bringing that
that series forward it but it's also
interesting because we didn't get a
gears of war remastered for two or three
we just got that first one yeah so i i'm
not totally sure how they're gonna slot
that into the overall story is that
something that people even care about
with gears of war will it be like doom
doom i think was kind of a surprise hit
out of nowhere that was just like
visceral gameplay that's super fun
maybe gears of war could latch onto that
same kind of feeling and it would be
really cool i'm a little bit reticent to
start um i guess criticizing or worrying
about games because of their multiplayer
betas because doom was an exact example
of how wrong my expectations were coming
out of that um did i do either of you
guys play the beta for gears of war
multiplayer though gears of war for
multiplayer played i played a little bit
of it and in a way it felt like exactly
like gears of war multiplayer has always
been and in a sort of a
frustrating way or like an uninspiring
way um so i guess i hope that's not the
case for the single player campaign um
moving on crackdown 3. peter i want to
talk to you about this a little bit
because crackdown 3 they showed off a
demo of it you know a couple of years
ago and they sort of briefly showed this
like cloud com cloud i guess processing
physics processing aspect of the game
you've seen a lot more of that now right
so
you were talking about it very excitedly
yeah i played a live demo at gamescom
last year in germany uh late summer and
it's essentially like
okay everyone is playing in the cloud
and in the cloud we have
multiple like
xbox equivalents stacked together yeah
and using all that processing power the
entire environments were destructible
and it was just insane to see not only
that happen but how players
playing on different consoles could
influence that and i've never seen
tech like that on a console before and
granted it wasn't playing from the
console but that was my gateway to it
yeah and uh so as far as you're
concerned
it was just running on your machine and
all these buildings were falling down
right it was like realistically not just
falling down but like different aspects
of them were shattering based on what
you did
to cause that impact right and uh it it
was the most impressive piece of
technology i've seen on a console ever
that's incredible so i mean yeah i mean
it might depend on your connection you
know who knows yeah might depend on a
lot of factors but what i saw was was
great i bet microsoft are going to be
very very careful in their use of the c
word i know you know cloud has kind of
become this uh this uh sensitive topic
it sort of harpens back to the magic era
as well which i feel like they're trying
to get away from yeah yeah interesting
though cracker i mean crackdown one
fantastic game crackdown two maybe a
little bit too quick off the heels to
really get people sort of excited about
it but yeah i think fans would be
looking forward to a new crackdown um a
game we've barely seen much of at all
sea of thieves this sort of uh it looks
like an mmo style
pirate pirate thing any interest in that
at all just i mean we're probably going
to see it this year
we need to see more of it and i was kind
of taken with assassin's creed 4 black
flag that that right that was a game
that surprised me with how much i
enjoyed that that whole ocean warfare
aspect of it and like living on the high
seas and see if they seems like it could
tap into that same feeling of being a
semen out on the out on the ocean we all
love semen
but
yeah it would be a lot of fun i think it
has the potential to be a lot of fun
seeming not with it
um i've also heard rumors of i guess the
battletoads thing's been floated around
for a little while yeah any interest in
that at all yeah i mean i yeah if if
they can capture what those games did so
well which includes bringing back david
wise to the soundtrack right um they
could make something really fun in their
hands but what they did so well was make
you hate playing video games and want to
destroy your controller oh dry a little
bit in the corner
those games were so odd and just out
there and they didn't really make much
sense when you compared it to like the
rest of this like the stuff around it
and uh this is a good opportunity for
them to to recapture that but as we're
seeing with like a lot of games that are
trying to recapture nostalgia there's a
right way and a wrong way to do it yeah
and it's it's a delicate balance yeah
for every ducktales there's a doom yeah
i guess um speaking of controllers new
xbox one controller a lot of people
saying that now that the elite has sort
of gone out there and sold and some of
that uh tech might be rolled back into a
new xbox especially if they're a new
xbox controller especially if they're
going to release a slim version right
they usually sort of update those skus a
little bit
i don't i actually don't put a lot of
faith into that particular rumor really
it seems like you do have the the two
different types of controllers you have
your standard controller and you have
this really nice high-end one and i
think they'll continue keeping that
separation i i don't know that the high
end controller is necessarily sold that
well it's at a price point that's enough
for me to even get a little bit but it
is a really cool controller and i think
those two ideas will stay separate and
one of the things that will hopefully
save people money perhaps over time is
to sort of uh increased support for pc
that we're sort of seeing uh in on the
xbox one platform um
perhaps they'll dive into you know we're
seeing a lot of like walls coming down
in terms of online connectivity between
the pc and the console and other
consoles as well um and then i guess
with something like quantum break where
that was originally an xbox one
exclusive and then it came out day and
date on pc and is this something you
think we're going to see more and more
of peter they definitely said that they
will be putting every xbox one exclusive
on pc right now so that's a thing like
yes we will see more of that um and just
going back to what i was saying earlier
about the pc to you know a stick
streaming on your tv yeah um i think
that would be
i really do think that they're going to
do that if they don't that that seems
just like an obvious missed opportunity
to me
um
there was rumors on the giant bombcast
last week i think of uh halo 5's
campaign being playable on pc and that
microsoft were doing tests internally up
in seattle because they did release
forge mode on pc or something but the
actual campaign itself so that would be
interesting i wonder if they'll i mean
that's probably not the best example of
a game they would want to be pulling
over onto pc but i just i just love how
like halo is like a thing it's like oh
and maybe we can get it on pc who knows
it's like why wouldn't you just put it
on pc what is your problem like do it uh
forza as well another one we're we've
seen the sort of little pc snippet
they're putting together uh forza
horizon 3 a lot of people saying that
that's a dead on this year that it might
be set down under and we don't have any
of our australian colleagues in here to
give us the scoop on that but uh what do
you think about that one i mean forza
seems to be like an annual thing for
microsoft at this stage yeah at this
point and i think it's a horizon year
isn't it that's yeah right
it's like called like you can set your
calendar by call of duty so
it seems like a good guess i
i for me personally not something that's
the most exciting both because it is
annual and because i'm not as big of a
racing guy i know you're super into f1
and all the passing games
but yeah but even for me
it sort of it straddles that line of the
sim again the arcade in a way that i've
played a sort of enough of those games
andy bauman who used to work here was a
massive fan of the forza rising games i
think he wanted to give forza rise in
two game of the year if he had his way
um so there is a market for this you
know people are really into it and you
know the tuscan sort of the world of
forza horizon 2 really look great as
well for that console which is very
important to them and that's kind of all
the microsoft rooms that i have here you
guys have anything else uh you're
thinking about or something that we saw
leaked today you don't know how much
credence to give it but images of a dead
rising four right yeah yeah it's like
i could see that i mean we'll it'll
definitely be another xbox one pc
exclusive
i seems believable totally i mean it's
been if there was a launch title dead
rising three was so i mean they've had a
lot of time to to make that engine
better to make a better experience
because dead rising three wasn't
the systems no i wasn't super excited
about that one i actually went back and
played it uh when i got my wisdom teeth
taken out a couple of months ago and
that made it so much better it but it
was surprising how
it looks like an early console life
cycle game you know so
you know and at that stage we're sort of
lotting the fact that there was all of
these zombies on screen and yes really
when you go back and play it you're like
whatever you know
we now like hitman is a game i was
playing last weekend and that's got way
better crowd dynamics so speaking of
games making a comeback what if we see a
new sunset overdrive i'm sorry my phone
is ringing oh great who's that yeah yeah
is that a
is that microsoft insider yeah shut up
um i would love to see sunset overdrive
return oh totally yeah if yeah if they
announced that overdrive too that might
be the one game that i think would
really get people excited rather than
like a gears of war 4 and another forza
and like just all these just okay yeah
we've seen that you know sunset
overdrive is one of those games where
like when it goes on sale for like 15
bucks you see people on twitter like i
know you didn't play this game yes you
have no reason not to play it at this
price i was one of those people and
played it for the first time again
during wisdom tooth time and was totally
shocked at how it's best in class for
those types of games for that type of
like infamous you know open world
jaunting like crackdown style yeah
at the very least they should release it
for pc yeah like it's crazy that they
haven't done that already i agree um
cool so that's all our microsoft
drummers if you have any uh of yourself
or if there's anything that you're
particularly interested in uh let us
know in the comments below
all right gentlemen let's move on we got
a lot of stuff to talk about sony
playstation uh it was gdc that all the
rumors started floating around about the
playstation neo the 4.5 this updated
version of the playstation 4 since then
it seems like everyone and their mother
has had a leak coming out of somewhere
um about this
console so before we get into their sort
of their games and their virtual reality
stuff um justin first of all playstation
4.5 pretty much dead on to be shown at
e3
it has to right you've had so many leaks
you've had so much information come out
e3 is the perfect time to introduce a
new console like this and it feels like
it's about time in that console life
cycle that we you have a really high
adoption for playstation 4 they're the
dominant console hands down what's a way
that you can get a little bit more
[Music]
subscribers get more people playing it
have a slightly more powerful system and
something that's going to play into vr
like you need something that will
probably support virtual reality in a
better way because i i think when they
were showing the virtual reality systems
it's needed some kind of pass-through
otherwise so there's a everyone always
talks about that and
maybe i'm misinformed but from what i
understand that box does not do any
actual processing like the way we
traditionally think about cpus and gpus
doing stuff from what i think sony has
said that box is there to handle
communication of data okay so not the
actual process like routing data or
something right yeah so that would
include audio and video that needs to go
to the headset right it can't just be a
straight cable yeah in that regard um so
i while i don't think that if there is a
follow-up playstation 4 that it might
help vr i don't think that it's going to
be like this is the one for vr it would
be like we would see with regular games
they would just see an incremental
improvement um
[Music]
based on the rumors anyway the thing i
think is really interesting with this is
it's not weird to get it's not different
to get a new console in the middle of a
life cycle we've gotten the xbox 360 s
back in the day yeah you get smaller
versions of consoles that are usually
incrementally more powerful but this is
the ps1 playstation 364 is the only
console i can think of that in the
saturn
that did not get like all right
but this is one where they're
specifically or people are really
highlighting this is a more powerful
version it is the same console it'll
play the same games but it's also going
to be a better console and that's a
really interesting tactic of course it's
not marketing that's not what they're
going for this is what's leaked out this
is what we're we're latching on to so
it'll be interesting to see how they
spin that as well yeah totally do you
think this is like the new normal peter
where like instead of was having these
sort of you know incremental skus which
obviously change elements of the console
based on you know
[Music]
the parts that they're buying for
instance and whatnot um but do you think
the idea of this sort of incremental
like in within the same generation
console is is you know something we're
used to on the pc side you think that's
the way we're gonna see it going from
now on i mean possibly you know we think
of generations in terms of like these
you know rightly so like you know big
chunks of time right if sony was to come
out with a playstation 5 just play
devil's advocate we wouldn't then say
this a next generation playstation 5
right right right so if we look at it
that way like i think eventually we will
see a playstation 5. but will it be such
a big leap from what we think the neo is
or what might be a follow-up to the neo
before the playstation 5.
no i think we're going to see these
smaller upgrades over time persist but
but we will still latch on to the
concept of this is a new era
of something but the days of these huge
gaps and technological performance
between uh hardware iterations i think
is done nintendo has done a great job
with that with the the 3ds in particular
but before the 3ds the the game boy
advance and like how all of those bled
into one another you weren't able you
were always able to play your back had a
lot of catalogue of games on the new
system and then when they came up with
another version it would cut out some of
the backwards compatibility and
introduce new functions for new games
yeah and get punished for holding on to
that gameboy micro um i mean it's
basically the same we've seen in you
know apple phones and you know i guess
phones just in general and tablets and
whatnot um yes it'll be very interesting
to see the specs i mean that's what
everyone wants to see right xbox one's
new specs the scorpio and and 4.5 uh
stepping away from that hardware into
sony's other hardware thing the
playstation vr previously known as
project morpheus um
the second and the trifecta of
matrix-themed uh hardware and iterations
we're going to enjoy um where are we do
you think with with playstation vr right
because we're now living in a you know
post-oculus you know post-htc vive world
where people have gotten hands on it
seems like there's a lot of interest
there for a while and we're kind of
tapering off again where some people
have bought them and you know they're
now trying to get them in front of
stores to get people to buy them what do
you think about interest over
[Music]
playstation vr peter the advantage they
have one is cost two is the uh
ubiquitous you know number of
playstations that are out there but
right the the real thing for me are the
sort of the properties that will be used
to create vr games uh whereas a lot of
the games that we're seeing on vive and
oculus are these new things that no one
really understands like who are these
characters what is this world
playstation vr will be able to leverage
like sony's you know great history of
titles and you know you know
not that i'm counting this among the
great history of titles but you know you
see like the uh the horror game that
they're putting on that sort of the on
rails uh yeah i know what we're talking
about
we're good
[Music]
yeah
thank you yes uh and psychonauts is
getting a thing and that's not
necessarily a sony property or anyone
that was ever exclusive to their
consoles but rush of blood russia
bloodshore yeah so um but yeah i think
they'll be leveraging familiar
properties to get people interested into
it i don't think we're going to see
many grand experiences i just recently
finished playing insomniac's edge of
nowhere all right yeah which i believe
was made in tandem with oculus studios
so that won't be coming to playstation
vr but that was one of the first vr
experiences that i played where it felt
like a full
[Music]
game like kronos was there as well yeah
it's a really good game
but there was something about edge of
nowhere that felt even more uh advanced
in that regard and providing the full
experience so i don't know if we're
gonna get a lot of that sort of thing
out of sony um i think that will take
another year or so or even be able to
play
[Music]
experiences that we already have in vr
and uncharted 4 it seems like it might
be a weird fit for for vr but when i
think about like being able to pull back
the camera and and see all around the
world right because they put so much
time and attention and care into these
huge environments and expanses like it
would be so cool to have like a little
nathan drake running along on the table
and i can look over and see this huge
statue in the forest yeah sort of like
the what they do with like the hitman go
and lara craft go stuff but like for
yeah totally for now and proper yeah i
mean at a certain stage even if there's
just a virtual reality option that isn't
like super i mean you need to have your
sort of tekken 7 is supposed to have it
great
can't wait i'm sure actually there would
be an audience for that but just not for
me um let's talk about i guess the other
aspect of that we talked about it with
our microsoft discussion which you can
also check out if you're watching this
on gamespot on youtube go check it out
um
you can all we also sort of talked about
how you know what happens with sony and
the
reaction we have to that is so much
dependent on what we then or what we
have heard from microsoft earlier that
morning um do you think if microsoft
come out and do some sort of tie-in with
um oculus that then the playstation vr
ends up looking like sort of
the lesser of the two of those maybe to
people who aren't enthusiasts um in
terms of gaming you know how they care
about it because i think oculus is a
they were really notable because they
were like okay we're doing vr we're
going to do it first we know what we're
doing and they caught everyone's
attention facebook bought us for yeah
yeah yeah and at this point i think what
it's devolved down to for them because
vive has kind of stepped in right and
sort of taken over the hardcore
enthusiast market right oculus is far
more mainstream and if anything i think
microsoft needs to latch on to that and
that'll be good for them to sort of
define that but when it comes to people
you know like us who really care about
traditional gaming in that way and how
that can be brought into vr i think
playstation vr will
be able to stand on its own in that
regard and not necessarily be compared
one to one with oculus
okay a couple of games to jump into uh
first of all i guess we're going to
probably see some no man's sky now
especially that it's been delayed a
little bit yeah you know if someone is
going to be the same focus though like
that was a big part of the show and
that's something i really want them to
back off on i don't want to see a lot of
it i want to see how the economy works
like all this sort of like what you do
with what you gather and what you
discover like show me more of the that
nuance that kind of thing even i that
would be a cool one to see if they have
virtual reality support that would be
you know that might sell a bunch of um
playstation viewers as well uh moving on
uh god of war four what have sony santa
monica been working on for the past
couple years i guess they released god
of war ascension
um
battle all-stars was that even right
that was somebody else i think that was
somebody else but the i guess you know
it feels like a sort of a mainline god
of war have been rumored for a while one
without kratos like a starting sort of
fresh thing and i think the rumor is
like setting it in norse mythology okay
that'd be pretty cool would be yeah it's
interesting everyone like gets kicked
off there europe europe's real happening
hot right now which are three everyone
else the same problem i have though with
this is the the issues we were
describing with gears of war four right
like god of war made such a big splash
and it continued to for a while but it
was helped somewhat by
the advent of the playstation 3. like i
sort of like jump-started the series
again but since then it hasn't really
achieved the same sort of uh like renown
or attention totally so
maybe playstation 4 can help elevate it
a little bit in terms of graphics but
really like what sort of gameplay things
are they going to do they're going to
surprise us yeah it can't just be the
world that it's set in it can't just be
that it's a little bit prettier than
before yeah i think it really needs to
find a new way to define itself and if
it is indeed coming and it is how they
describe like i hope
they can leverage the world to do that
yeah that'd be great but you can rip the
eyeballs out of all sorts of new things
totally different eyeball ripping do you
say eyebrows or eyeballs eyeballs
i just steal eyebrows and put them up
characters you never know how i feel
because ah
layers of emotion all written all over
your face and another rumor that's been
floating around i mean sony have had the
spider-man ip for a while when it comes
to the movie stuff uh word that perhaps
sucker punch are working on a spider-man
game
like i don't know if that's true or not
or if it's just that fanboy wish because
infamous is a fun game right but with
that spider-man skin it would be perfect
it just like fits that so well
but i i don't know how true that is and
how much that is just that's something
that would be really cool it seems like
it would fit like a dream yeah i mean
second song was a fun game i really
enjoyed that i'd like to see them you
know maybe take a deeper stab at it um
yeah like i guess what else
we don't know what else our studio is
working on at the moment right um
[Music]
local boys so we'll have to see yeah
there it is infamous seconds son jumping
around don reichert's in that game for
some reason it's very weird really yeah
yeah he's like a bunch of the like
russian terrorist dudes oh that makes
like skins yeah totally
like real life yeah
there's another great um resume floating
around a linkedin post for knack 2.
[Music]
yeah mark cerny
max cerny's knacky journey
sony journey yeah i mean i think about
playstation launch games that i was
really hoping would get a reboot that i
just wanted to dive into again i
immediately think of knack
they would be tone deaf if they
announced mac 2. i feel like
i hadn't heard of that game
again in years until i had heard about
that that
to be but then mark cerny's a powerful
figure and so yeah you know what i mean
like yeah architect of the playstation 4
weird guy to interview
um
which denotes power i know i wish we had
a recording of martin gaston's interview
where mark just stared at him and said
nothing for a minute and yeah 30 seconds
um but uh yeah i mean maybe
[Music]
you know he's the dude who made a bunch
of cool old playstation games he could
probably get away with doing another one
right it wasn't a bad game it was just
like fine right the fine game it was
exactly like peter talked about earlier
where it's a game that doesn't feel like
it needs to be on this next platform
it's just this is another very
old-school game that's very pretty and
nice to look at but
what does it do
[Music]
that elevates gay that makes this in any
way a playstation 4 game yeah
who knows i bet it'll turn off i bet
mac2 will turn off i just i put money on
it you know it'd be great is if they had
knack on screen and then to sort of
bring in uh naughty dog they had crash
bandicoot just like donald trump and
bust him up and be like wrong it's me
i mean yeah you know we're not getting
at the spoilers crash bandicoot has
reappeared recently uh do you think
maybe they they go back to the
the bandicoot go back to the bandicoot
water no i actually don't i'd be very
shocked if naughty dog made a new crash
it's kind of a one-note game like it's
fun but like what does a new crash
bandicoot look like it'd be the same
problem sonic's had forever right like
they already did the cart racing like
sonic yeah
they have to they haven't done a
fighting game
there you go maybe a collectible card
game yeah yeah we'll see anything else
in terms of sony rumors you guys want to
talk about i mean 4.5 seems to be the
thing everyone has their eyes on
i mean there has to be something sony is
not i wouldn't say a wild card but
there's always there's going to be a
surprise and i feel like we're not going
to see it we're not going to have
gameplay we're not going to be able to
do it but we're going to get an
announcement for it we're going to see
some really exciting trailers both for
xbox and and sony playstation there's
going to be something that i can't even
guess and that's what has me most
excited i'm just going to be super
predictable and bring up kojima oh of
course yeah cause there was that image
that we you know we got the other day
that shows the face of the character
like within like the mascot and yeah
what are you saying i'm i'm coming
uh
i'll keep coming i'll keep coming and so
that's disgusting
there's
there's two things about that uh one was
we had uh producer kenichiro mazumi on
record as saying this is not an image of
or from the game we're working on right
and which a lot of people took as this
is not going to be anything that is
related to a game right he sends
clarified with us like no that's not
what i meant what i meant was this is
not a screenshot right you can decide
whatever you think this is we're not
commenting on that so with that plus
with the fact that people were looking
at that image and realized if you
compare this angle to the hero shot of
norman reedus from the press materials
for silent hills right it's like the
same eye the same ifold
yeah so i think we're getting to a point
now where we're not going to see like
maybe a trailer we might just see well
we might see a teaser yeah of what
they're working on because we know
kojima is making a game that will be on
playstation 4. that's kind of wouldn't
that be mental though because you're
literally talking about like less than
six months passing since he formed this
studio
but he's has to have something that the
world like you want to have something
he's going to show and i mean he's a
veteran he knows this industry it sounds
like like when you get your band
together you're a teenager and you make
your website before you've written a
song you know it's like well perhaps
but you know i i at the same time i
think that there's there's a good chance
that anything i mean look i mean we
we put up an image
of just a character that people have
already seen before like 90 of that
character and it was i think the highest
trafficking story on the site really
yeah all right so anything that they do
will get people's attention and to not
capitalize on that opportunity is again
a missed opportunity so why wouldn't
they that'd be great love to see it
we'll have to wait and see not too much
longer only a couple of days uh less
than a week before sony takes to the
stage on monday ash probably four
o'clock or something like that
at a time at a time at a time to be
determined it's not determined we know
it's on the internet somewhere go google
it let us know what you think about sony
in the comments below
gentlemen
let's talk about the other console
manufacturer who may or may not be
showing more than one game at e3 i don't
know oh you see oh no no not the pc game
show i did doing it again this year
you're doing it again this was a weird
show last year it was a weird show last
year i think this year they're doing it
right before either right before ubisoft
okay and they had to bump it back they
were like oh the car was going to run
into that we need to scale it back
wasn't it like four hours last time yeah
and they finished with sean murray and
it was a weird thing anyway we're not
talking about pc talking about the other
side of the power
line of consoles nintendo
they're not showing the nx this year are
they though justin are they not showing
it they've been very explicit that
they're not oh
okay which is weird that's such a
nintendo thing to do to go to the
biggest gaming show in the world and not
bring the thing that everybody is
curious about the thing that the most
interesting thing they have working on
the thing that their biggest game is
going to come out on next year right and
not talk about it but they are showing
the game yeah zelda's going to be zelda
a launch title for the nx yeah is not
going to be on the nx it's going to be
on the wii u
oh okay nintendo that's think about it
this way like they're trying to compete
with so many different people and
nintendo being with you know what they
are they would stand to benefit from
waiting like a month after e3 right and
just doing a nintendo direct to me like
this is it this has been part of like a
very long slow crawl out of e3 though
right like between stop doing a press
conference to the direct stuff and then
the treehouse sort of being where they
were announcing things um let's talk a
little bit about the hardware sort of
aspects of this peter we talked briefly
about it um last week about how
the there was like a certain chipset
that they were like using which may or
may not be connected with yes so the
rumor is they may be using the tegra
chip i made by nvidia which has been
used in their various shield devices
right and and what that does is it
allows
almost playstation 3 type graphics on
mobile devices okay you sacrifice a
little bit of resolution and some
graphical flourishes um but it's also
got some hardware built in to help
stream uh to uh another device or a
capture stream from another device so
they were famously streaming from a pc
to these things like over wireless and
stuff and that's like not fancy not
totally dissimilar to the wii u tablet
not totally dissimilar um but but it
worked like over internet connections
you didn't want to do it locally um so
you know if they go with the tegra you
could say okay that's cool and maybe
nvidia will be you know providing a
stronger gpu for the console itself if
that is a thing people talk about them
having a handheld that will be docked in
a console
but if nintendo doesn't make a serious
effort to at least be close to the power
that we're seeing in the current
versions of the new console or the
modern consoles
they're fools right they can't rely on a
mobile chip to compete
on a console so i don't think that
that'll be the way it works at the same
time it has to mat it has to have some
compatibility with the wii u which is
something that we see every every
iteration of consoles that they have
some problem porting games over or
making that cross compatibility with
especially on on on console hardware but
this has to play wii u games because the
nx or zelda wii u is going to be a
launch title for the nx as well well
yeah and they've talked a little bit
about developing middleware that allows
porting of games uh cross generation um
and from other consoles so it it seems
like uh there will be a way for them to
do that it'll largely depend on the
architecture of the hardware for a while
everyone was thinking oh they're just
going to go the same route as sony
microsoft and do an x86 chip which is
what you see from like intel on their pc
line um but they might actually go power
pc which is what we used to see in
macintosh's back in the day right not
max macintosh
and that provides a different sort of
thing but if you're doing that between
generations it'll help yeah uh moving on
to the games i mean there's not really
much to talk about except zelda wii u
emily rogers has rumored that the zelda
you will have voice acting and that you
can select whether you want to play as a
male or female character at the start
and that'll be an interesting update
yeah so you can hear link either go oh
oh yeah
perfect yeah
wait what game are you playing zelda
zelda
well link looking forward to it
well definitely there's there's a reason
nintendo is going to be able to build
almost their entire e3 presence around
zelda wii u because they know that this
is their tentpole title that all of us
are excited for it and even though i
don't think that is going to be the only
thing and they've said on record now
that
[Music]
they're going to have their second day
of the treehouse live yeah talking about
other games like pokemon go it's not
going to be 100 zelda but they could
like i wouldn't have been surprised
i would have believed it if the only
game playable at the show the only game
they talked about was zelda because
there's so much hype and excitement
around the game that is a game that
people have said i want to buy a wii u
but i'm waiting for zelda i just hope i
don't have to use the gamepad with that
thing if they force me to use a gamepad
for zelda i will be very i mean like
like as a shield or like as a sword god
don't even give me the idea
i feel like with nintendo we always get
the craziest rumors because nobody
really knows and there's a language
barrier involved there as well and a
cultural buyer significant one so you
know a lot of these rumors probably we
know pokemon go perhaps are going to be
shown there as well that's dead has that
been confirmed that they're going to
show pokemon i think they said that
[Music]
at the treehouse live they're going to
talk about pokemon go okay we're going
to talk about monster hunter generations
games that are coming to 3ds it was sun
and moon
i i don't think they said whether
they're going to talk about sun and moon
which is really weird that they would
talk about go but not sun and moon uh
there's a rumor as well that mother 3
might finally be getting localized for
north american markets yes yes it is
that is going to happen i believe this
so at the beginning of this year we have
a we have a predictions article for
2016. oh here we go because i totally
forgot about it and we're going to come
visit revisit this at the end of the
year my prediction was mother 3
announced this year it's going to happen
you made that prediction two years ago i
make this prediction every year
but it came out so but this year it at
least came out in japan so i have
strength behind me they just have to
localize it and there are localizations
there's already translations they can
totally use those
but didn't didn't
the guy behind that go on record is
saying nintendo has not contacted me and
like any efforts i've made have been met
with resistance nintendo though they're
they don't want to use somebody else's
they're like oh we'll take care of what
i'm saying so there's not already a
translation it's nintendo not an intent
don't
do nintendo last thing on this if you
have before we jump into bethesda and
ubisoft and ea and everyone else um if
you had a wish list if you had one thing
that you would like nintendo to announce
this year
what would it be
[Music]
super mario galaxy 3 oh god
for nx for both both yeah i played it on
wii u i like my words i played on wii
uh let's not go crazy played on pc can't
stop me get that pc
hack over uh what about yourself justin
apart from mother 3 and being wrong so
they've already said that they're going
to be having some mobile games coming
out so we know we're going to get a fire
emblem i think animal crossing on mobile
right okay cool experiences i still want
animal crossing on wii u i know that i'm
in the minority for this you want to be
a prisoner at home as well as on your
commute on the toilet or like if it ties
into the mobile game and i can play on
the wii u and my 3ds and i can just like
be harvesting vegetables and fish all
the time that's dangerous eric tay would
get into that that's what would happen
maybe put it on a home how we can trade
vegetables and get like a stock you can
trade vegetables in real life and you
don't do it seriously
do you want an apricot i'll give you a
peach actually none of those are
vegetables but
all right you can't in real life
we'll know more about what nintendo are
showing off if there is any surprises uh
this time next week i guess the
treehouse is running the whole show
right holding after the show or just
have to wait nintendo
[Music]
announces what like the day before
saturday it's like boom next there you
go
screw all you guys it'll be a good idea
imagine we get three hard work revisions
in one year that'd be amazing um yeah so
let us know what you'd like nintendo to
announce in the comments below and hit
subscribe if you want to get more hot e3
content all right gentlemen we're going
to swap it out peter brown justin hey
we'll get the hell off my set
we got a bunch of brits sitting down
dave jewett sitting in the wings no
better person to talk about bethesda and
tamar hussein is here as well
foxhound shirt in here shoulda had you
on for sony i was ready oh my god
congratulations
day two of ramadan you're doing all
right i'm doing all right yeah yeah
chill all good yeah yeah not too bad
i'll probably have to make up some when
i get back right but because you're on
your little you're on a trip a little
break thankfully which is yeah well i
was about to say the sun is probably
real bad in london at the moment but
have you seen the videos i have not is
it
[Music]
yeah there is a great video of like a
like a ford focus or something driving
straight into like what they think is a
puddle and it's a lake and it's a bunch
of london lads standing around where
cameras calling the driver a bed end
that's the most london thing i have ever
seen god i love that city it's
incredible dave have you been to san
francisco before no this is my first
time here how are you enjoying it i love
it so far apart from the minus sunburn
though oh really
how many people have you seen trying to
hack you with their telephones as you
walk around watch dogs i mean if they're
doing it right i've not seen them at all
so hopefully my data is still safe yeah
i guess we'll find out about that
soon enough uh gentlemen we have a lot
of stuff to talk about today first of
all in terms of software we've just done
all the hardware stuff now we're going
to jump into software the first folks to
talk about bethesda last year they did
their first e3
conference it ended up being the e3
conference i mean between showing
fallout 4 announcing it's saying it was
coming out later that year pip-boy
edition launching a mobile game doom
like the amount of insane stuff that
they showed at that i mean dishonored it
was it was an absolute barn burner um
looking at this year there was a lot of
rumors about some of the stuff that we
may or may not see first one i want to
talk about with you dave skyrim
remastered i feel like i've heard this
rumor for the past three years at e3
it's either happening this year or it's
not happening at all right yeah i mean
we've heard about it so many times
and i mean i'd love to jump back into
that world again but at the same time i
feel like it's also maybe not the most
deserving elder scrolls game maybe a bit
of a controversial opinion right i mean
would you prefer to see oblivion get i
mean
oh really okay fair enough i mean the
way i look i mean he didn't say
daggerfalls
or arena either either remaster a game
that isn't only five years old yeah
because everyone's already played skyrim
to death and it still looks amazing
especially with mods but you either
remaster a game that's like way
inaccessible now like morrowind yeah or
you explore the rest of tamriel like you
could go to black isle the home of the
argonians and see what they're doing all
right i'm gonna be the mr bethesda in
the suit and be like
talk some sense into you
skyrim is the most successful of the
elder scrolls series
it would be right it would be exactly
and if you were going to remaster anyone
you picked the one that people have
current nostalgia for right you know
it's still in the consciousness of
gamers socially you know arrow to the
knee memes oh gosh
are still going skyrim mods are what
paved the way for fallout mods yeah and
bethesda's kind of interest in
delivering mods across platforms and
they have a crap ton of mods already
ready to go right they've just launched
obviously fallout mods so they know how
the flow works the pipeline works yeah
i've got that stuff out it's almost as
if fallout 4 mods was was kind of worked
out in order to bring skyrim mods back
yeah because i mean it's got so much
legacy to it and to be honest like
everyone loves skyrim like we have
nostalgia for for morrowind and oblivion
and that kind of stuff but like the
amount of people that still talk about
skyrim right now and i just like
as soon as you announce it i will throw
my money at you and just posting
pictures of frye from futurama being
like take my money like there's millions
of them out there it makes perfect sense
for him to do oblivion
skyrim instead of bleeping it wasn't
until you mentioned morrowind or even
like do you want to feel really old it's
been 10 years since oblivion came out
that was like one of the first games
that i bought on it i love that game
yeah remember getting that getting that
thick box version or that one yeah it
looked like a freaking manuscript it was
awesome i was actually the idiot that
bought horse armor as well oh you were i
did yeah god the start of dlc that's
what you all did as i said that they
pretty much
have done
uh skyrim they got it over it was a
story a while back yeah we ported it
we've done totally so i think that's
running on xbox yeah like enough people
had seen it
through some sort of channels that even
last year was like oh it's definitely
happening yeah it was it was clearly
something they kind of used to explore
developing for these consoles and we're
like no if we just hit
press discs
but imagine how good that rain and water
would look that morrowind dankness in hd
uh let's move on though because we got a
bunch of games uh to go through here uh
doom released last month massive
surprise success it sold well and
excessive it was half a million sometime
last week it's probably pushed way past
that now as well and that's only on pc
uh do you think we'll see some dlc for
this thing like best case scenario we'll
get some single player dlc worst case
scenario we'll get some multiplayer dlc
totally totally totally with you on that
yeah dave what do you think i mean i've
played into the ending and no spoilers
but the ending was like you'll see more
of us okay right so i mean it's pretty
implied we'll see more of doom but like
tam said the single player was one of
the best shooter stories that i've
played in years but the multiplayer i
was just like
yeah it's totally developed by a
different you know critical assembly who
did it or sort of of call of duty and
halo you know multiplayer side project
fame um yeah there was nothing wrong
with it it's just it's so it's like just
yes it's so blasey from the single play
experience yeah it's like we've figured
out how to boil doom back down to its
essence we want to remind you what first
person shooters like this why you love
them i'm gonna give you that and then
multiplayer remember this modern crap
you've got yeah yeah one surprise yeah
uh i mean it's a long tradition of doom
you know launching map packs so
hopefully we'll see more of that uh
let's get follow four out of the way do
you think we're gonna see any more i
mean they have a pipeline for a bunch
more expansion packs yeah do you think
they're gonna announce anymore i feel
like the the cliff on fallout 4 has been
yeah very surprising i mean so you you
host and run our fallout 4 show right
yeah so like fallout 3 seemed to just be
forever people were like modding it and
playing it skyrim same sort of thing uh
like i have a similar experience on my
youtube channel doing fallout 4 like uh
streams and stuff just
you can see it like there's just not
that much interest in it so hype just
kind of plummeted yeah but what i was
looking at is the is the time difference
between fallout 3 and new vegas and new
vegas was way better than fallout 3.
it's totally agreed my favorite fallout
game
um the gap there was two years right so
in theory we could see like obsidian
right
like yeah they take up the reigns the
same
happened with fallout 3 and new vegas
maybe they could be skulking but then
you wonder if you know todd howard's
team well i guess i wouldn't be taught
her team then but you wonder maybe if
bethesda as a whole are done announcing
games a year and a half out because they
had so much success with fallout 4. true
yeah they said that they when they uh
announced a season pass and then raised
the price of the season they said
they've expanded the scope of it to
include more and if they have more to
work with in terms of they've got more
plans for dlc it wouldn't make sense for
them to announce something now
um instead of just being like waiting it
out because as you said interest is kind
of waning and i think that's partially a
symptom of how quickly it was announced
and then released and then just the
amount of hype around it would have
launched yeah geez there's very few
games again we were being pummeled by
fallout stuff around the launch so i
think a lot of people like kind of were
ready to draw a line under fallout and
be like all right i can sweep all that
stuff
on the rug now and just move on with my
gaming life but like if they want to
bring people back into it some story dlc
will go down a tree i reckon
let's move on a little bit here uh let's
putter through these these ones pretty
quick so we don't know too much about
them dishonored two uh we've already
seen you know that lovely uh trailer
presumably
and that kind of stuff do you gameplay
if we're getting played uh yeah so i
didn't get to play it but i watched one
of the gameplay designers play and um it
looked really cool it looks to be kind
of doing a lot of similar things but um
the interesting thing part of it part of
it is the way the world kind of reacts
to you and the way you can mess around
with weird supernatural powers cool so
it's just a matter of giving you more of
that and making the ai better and the
interesting thing about it was like they
clearly had more ambitious ideas for the
original dishonored right they were
hampered by someone by the technology
they couldn't like get the ai routines
down the way they wanted them to
interact okay and the thing that they
were really speaking about when i
interviewed them was like we need you
know we've got more power so we can do
crazier things and let you do crazier
things so it's definitely going to be
interesting to see what they do with it
that's exciting i mean i want a smarter
version of thief or something like that
that's what it feels like to be honest
excellent um wolfenstein will we see
another one of these i mean machine
games is rebirth of that
that was pretty i mean doom was a
surprise what was sign was equally as
surprised like what a wonderful the best
wolfenstein probably right
yeah yeah do you think we'll see anymore
especially after like the old world
blues that was kind of like a standalone
slash dlc experience but i adored the
first well the remake of of wolfenstein
and especially if they take the things
that they've learned from doom taking
these super old games kind of pulling on
your nostalgia strings yeah they're two
for two yeah now i just want them to
announce a new quake like and i wouldn't
have said that two months ago i would
have said don't touch quake we all still
remember quake four we're still getting
over it and the voice actress for was it
anya yes has she's basically let slip
that she's working the second one
wolfenstein yeah she said basically she
said i worked on this game series in the
past and i loved the bit when you got to
kill hitler yeah and now i'm working on
this series and i'm working on the
second part of it so like by reading
between the lines spoilers you get to
kill hitler again yeah it's interesting
you mentioned quake because the when i
played the doom multiplayer right it
reminded me more of quake than anything
else see that's a weird thing because
like a lot of people were saying that
because i guess the verticality that
existed in
quake
[Music]
there was none in quake 1 multiplayer
and quake 2 multiplayer it was all like
hook mod and arena stuff and it was like
rocket arena and things like that and
quake 3 was a bit more like oh there's
more people involved but there was an
interesting conversation i had last week
with a couple of folks in the office
about how
maybe it makes sense that like doom's
multiplayer was the way it was because
they're working on quake
like maybe they just make because it's
team like for all the modes in doom's
multiplayer are team based yeah god
knows what reason because team
multiplayer was not ever a thing i mean
even on do-more quake like unless you
talk about team arena which everyone's
wiped from their minds so like
imagine imagine if the reason they got
critical of somebody to work on that was
because hey you know what we're actually
going to be doing a new quake over here
yeah it turns out arena shooters are
real hot right now we've got cliff
bucinski making a new one blizzard are
even in on it like wait imagine like now
i believe them if they did a new quake
i'd throw my money at that as well right
yeah there's more faith in them now i
mean like they're two for two right now
they clearly understand their own
lineage again and yeah they understand
what made the original games great and
perhaps like you've convinced me
i'm ready for it like i believe it so
face yeah i was let's say facing world
it's one of the few studios that are
doing nostalgia correctly as well yeah
they're not they're not letting you down
they're pulling on your nostalgic heart
strings but then also delivering on that
love yeah it's amazing i'll have to wait
and see i guess uh last big one here i
guess and this one's been floating
around for a while and it sounds like
this is not going to be anything to do
with the one we saw before
uh which human head was working on but
there is a lot of words that prey to
maybe resurfacing um jason schreier uh
there was a
[Music]
he kind of threw it into the end of one
of his news posts last week but then in
the comments he added something else
saying is over okataku all i've heard is
that they're announcing it at e3 i'm not
100 sure though i do know it's code
named danielle and is under development
at arcane austin
and that this is totally new prey too it
might even be called something else now
at this stage or now sorry uh now
[Music]
and not the one we saw in 2011 from
human head so arcane austin i mean we
don't know what else they're working on
at the moment yeah they they haven't i
mean they're a studio that was
established by bethesda yeah and then
nothing has has come out of it which is
suspicious like they're clearly working
on something
um and everything that uh schweiz said
there kind of jives with what the news
the leaks the kind of rumors that have
happened so far with you know human head
being taken off the project yeah and
even kind of
fits in with bethesda canceling the
project they canceled prey too
right they didn't cancel they may have
just reinvented it as something else and
taken out all of that and given it to
arcane austin and let them run with it
yeah you know you never know what
happens in these situations maybe it
wasn't coming together or yeah i mean
arkhan austin worked out you know they
helped out arcane with a dishonored
designer too dark massage magic and all
that but yeah i'm a shame because the
the human head stuff that they showed
off a few years ago yeah really cool
like it looked good but you were also
wondering like how
this actually the game yeah we've been
burned a bunch on that uh a bunch of
times uh i guess the last
there
they should probably announce another
mobile game i don't know that last one
worked out pretty good real good
shelter i mean that's still on my phone
now yeah yeah it was really good at
wasting my battery at e3 when i was on
the toilet
like a solid week and sometimes not so
solid week on the toilet for a solid
week
um anything else you can think of
bethesda wise um i mean my hopes is more
doom more single player doom and if they
were
like fallout is one of my favorite game
series and i don't mind admitting that i
was a little bit disappointed
if they were to revitalize that give it
to obsidian and let them do what they
did to fallout 3 into new vegas yeah
that would make me happy i wonder if
that whether we like it or not they
might spend a little time on elder
scrolls online right yeah i'm sure it's
like kicking around i mean it's doing
well enough for them to keep it around
usually mmos that fail or aren't doing
too well or can
be quicker than this well tamiya
unlimited they went free to play it
seems to be doing okay so maybe we'll
get some i know they did thieves guild
recently so maybe we'll get some more
stuff to do with you know more expanding
and it's it's almost like the fact that
we like haven't talked about this at all
but like it is too early for todd
howard's team to start talking about a
new elder scrolls game yeah i mean you
think they're they're a big team like
as in
they have a few people working on a
bunch of different things so they could
be working on him like and put out a
small teaser never know i wouldn't play
it past them i don't expect it but i'll
uh don't put it but i wouldn't put it
past it like we said before i mean
whilst we'd all love a skyrim remastered
exploring the rest of that like super
rich world yeah there's still a bunch of
provinces in tamriel like half of the
entire world is still unexplored so yeah
let's let's get around to that maybe
even like a huge all of tamriel at once
just give it all to us and as much as we
love bethesda and and like to treat
their games as these all these distinct
things
they are clearly a lot of like overlaps
between fallout and uh skyrim in terms
of technology how they build the games
the fact that they have done fallout 4
now makes it considerably easier to move
on to another elder scrolls or maybe
that's what the skyrim
you know remastered is all about the
same with the gears of war remastering
running into gears of war 4 was then
like getting all that those assets back
in there's definitely bleed over in
terms of technology and design and that
kind of stuff so it would fast track
that process somewhat who knows they
might have a new ip up their sleeve as
well we'll have to wait and see uh thank
you both for coming on talking to us
dave jewish tomorrow's saying you stick
around we're going to stick around get
robbed crosstalk in a second uh let us
know what you think
of bethesda what they're going to show
off in the comments below and hit that
subscribe button we have a bunch of
videos there's eight of these videos
going up on our uh youtube channel if
you're watching this live of course you
don't have to wait
we got rob krusty here with his white
ass shirt what's going on buddy hey
friends how are you doing good
how are things how are video games doing
tell me tell me of the news i don't know
if i can replace dave dave is
irreplaceable but i'll try my best
everyone's replaceable right right
really in this commercial
capitalist world we live in started with
quite a cynical yeah you're right has
there been any leaks in the past hour
since we've been in here oh no man
[Music]
like we've had injustice we've had yeah
watchdog stuff dogs yeah we're about to
get into that in a second do you want to
get into it let's do it let's talk about
watchdogs all right ubisoft e3 2016.
they're going to be there showing off
video games they're not going to show
assassin's creed well they're not
launching one this year maybe they'll
show and who knows uh they might show
four honor they might show ghost recons
wildlands but they're probably gonna
show watch dogs too they're definitely
gonna show watchdogs too whether we like
it or not that that is happening you're
gonna get that watchdogs too if you're
watching this live then this is before
any sort of watch dogs 2 announcement
stuff
[Music]
we are thinking they're going to
announce something soon uh the leak at
the moment is that ign had a full page
takeover of their website i feel like i
feel bad for them it's it's unfortunate
that it happens i think it's kind of
funny
i know we all do it so when it happens
to them they have to laugh uber has been
really unlucky because they kept watch
dogs 2 under wraps yeah and then some
actor yeah yeah it was like
glasses on thanks ubisoft with sick
shades
that was the youtuber the actor before
him
he's a model and he's like i'm in watch
dogs too also check out my abs on
instagram and it was like oh wow he's
got some numbers like oh i guess you
you're in watchdogs too also watch dogs
too there's a picture so what the good
thing for you they haven't the game
hasn't been revealed yet but yeah still
like do the wonderful reveal of the game
at e3 yeah we don't know what it is all
we seem to be able to take from it is
that there is an african-american
protagonist and that it is set in san
francisco is there an african-american
protagonist that's what they do yeah so
there was a screen yeah yeah there was
an in it was an instagram shot from some
sort of mo-cap artist i mean two weeks
ago i think or maybe it was a little
longer than that a little longer than
that um of an african-american character
wearing basically
the sort of bandana
and then some glasses on the hat which
was like very very watch dogsy and then
basically that same character has picked
was on yeah there it is there and then
that same picture has appeared sort of
in better lighting on the front page
takeover for ign so that's very
interesting not just because obviously
diversity in games is very good but in
terms of like i'm somebody who lives in
oakland and used to live in san
francisco and like gentrification and
the sort of pushing out of minorities
within san francisco to oakland has been
so is like part of the day the life the
culture of this area so if they're doing
that then that's like
[Music]
well done because that like the two
stories that are happening around the
bay area is that the gentrification and
all you know rich people basically
pushing people out that and the tech
boom which is watchdogs perfect fits
them perfectly right i think that's i
think it's probably why they've chosen
san francisco right i mean it's a
[Music]
software center of of america basically
yeah the world
maybe yeah yeah so i think it's probably
a good idea for setting um
considering that gamespot and all the
big games companies are located in san
francisco that there's probably going to
be a lot of reviews about the accuracy
of
you know the location but um
you know i think ubisoft have a really
good chance with watch dogs too to
establish the franchise yeah this is
kind of the first watchdogs i thought it
was very forgettable and even it didn't
deliver on on any of it's like it's the
classic ubisoft maneuver right
assassin's creed one comes out and we
were like holy smokes this looks
incredible and it was shallow it had a
lot of good ideas but just did not
deliver on any of them yeah man i like
assassin's creed one i like it as well
is your favorite boy
yeah he's like the most arab dude in
video games ever and i was like he's
fully arab look at this guy
everyone else is like so
yeah
but like they always their second games
generally turn out to be much better
games are the ones that kind of
establish the template going forward
let's not forget the watchdogs one
trying to do so much i mean this is a
brand new ip yeah an open world game
released for
[Music]
six platforms
i mean that's a tall order isn't it yeah
that's a big ass and this was right at
like the sort of the
like the the highest point of ubisoft's
like massive machine
you know software development cycle like
of them pulling in thousands and
thousands and thousands of people you
see that culturally it seems to be a
little bit of okay they're they've taken
stock of what happened with assassin's
creed they've maybe is watchdogs was
probably like
one of the least impactful new ips
they've had in a long time especially in
the third person action adventures i was
not a fan of the first game at all i was
very disappointed by it but like even
i'm
there's something about this enough time
has passed i think they've they nobody
knows more about how good or bad a game
is and the people who made it like they
know they didn't need the media to say
entertaining they didn't need consumers
do you think that's true though because
when you're working on a game for so
long you don't really you can't see it
anymore right if you're so knee deep in
the game and i think that's
the case i feel like when it comes to
the end though they must they must be
able to like sit back and go right yeah
yeah yeah you hear a lot of stories
about developers saying like the the bug
that you're complaining about or the
thing the design element that you're
complaining about
we know
yeah i find developers try and justify a
lot of the time as well though right
no i feel like they like danny's thing i
feel like they do justify it but i feel
like deep down they know
[Music]
maybe we over that's because you
hardball interview them across there
let's get on to some more of the games
got a bunch of stuff to talk about uh
for honor i'm really surprised how like
much hype there is around this game
whenever we do our like weekly
breakdowns of all the games people are
searching for on game spot for honor has
been consistently there all year long
has been in the top like five five
sometimes seen so little of it yeah
hardly any and every time i think about
i think just think about like infinity
blade and right it feels like a mobile
game that's been expanded into like a
triple a title is it coming off the sort
of dark souls like people like it looks
like there's no dynasty words
it feels like it's literally infinite
like you're getting these one-on-one
encounters from point to point you know
dynasty warriors feels like a mass kind
of like large-scale battle type yeah
whereas this is like you you're a viking
and now you've got to fight a samurai
you use yeah
stuff to figure out how to deflect
attacks and it's so weird but like i'm
really interested in seeing more of it
mainly because that bearded dude was
like mega hype last time i'm like i
wanna i wanna know what he knows
like i wanna drink what he drinks yeah i
played for honor last year and um i
wasn't really expecting too much going
into it um but i had a lot of fun
playing it um so it's basically this big
massive battle sword sword fights and
and whatnot yeah and so you're playing
against loads of ais much like dynasty
where he's just slicing people down
but um
like you can also play other people
online okay as well at the same time you
get involved in like singular battles
within the battle precisely yeah so like
um you know in a um dark knight rises
for example there's that big massive
fight outside of that big building
they stare at each other in the middle
of that massive fight and they're like
yeah let's do this and nobody just comes
up and stabs them in the background no
they shoot them in their heads but like
the game is trying to recreate that at
that moment right you see someone who's
just as good as you like in a big battle
and face off against them and
i i was really impressed by it i thought
it was really fun and another game we
will probably see a lot of ghost recon
wildlands they've already started
trickling out information about it more
and more and that was a fun announcement
i like i'm a big fan of the ghost recon
like the old ones and then i actually
really liked advanced warfighter as well
um this
those i mean they fumbled the whole
four-player co-op thing a couple of
times though like the crew and like
there was a cup there was a while there
where every ubisoft game had multiple
the problem i have with with wildlands
is
um the ghost recon name existed before
ubisoft switched to this template
it was a rainbow six species exactly so
it means like it are they gonna try and
fit that game into an existing template
like is it going to be far cry plus the
crew right or far cry plus assassin's
creed or are they going to actually
create a new unique like you know ghost
recon style template for their own game
um i feel like if it's the the original
if there's using a current template i'll
be less interested in it whereas if
they're trying to like bring some of
what made the original ghost recon games
interesting and tactical and they're so
tactical they're like they're like
hidden in dangerous level of like
exactly moment's moment there's nothing
else that offers that right now that's
true like so the moment the studio is
flaunting how big the world is that's
their pr line i get so worried right
when publishers do that this is the
biggest land master ever gonna play
along it's like is there anything else
good about this game yeah because if
it's if it's just another open world
like i mean the crew was the biggest
thing ever and that's that was like the
big problem there the thing that worries
me is the division just came out right
and that's a that's a very easy like
copy paste yes just remove all these
dudes put some drugs in here ship it
which they presumably would have been
working on before the division has had
its sort of rise and fall i guess yeah
um although i'm sure it was very
profitable as well
yeah it'll be interesting like if it's
if it's just open world hitman with a
you know dabble of cocaine cowboys then
maybe that's pretty cool but you know
the devil's in the detail with these
type of games so we'll have to wait um
there's also a lot of news about props
possibly a new
aaa online game this has been floated
around for a while now yeah it that's a
you're gonna have to speculate on that
but i feel like a lot of people will
feel similar to me where they're like
ubisoft new aaa and you're like all
right and then they go online and you go
[Music]
or rabbits
are you telling me just dance online is
coming is that what's happening here
to be fair to ubisoft every e3 the past
four years five years now sure they've
stolen the show or threatened to steal
the show with a big new game usually a
new ip yeah that they've presented and
paraded really smartly right i mean the
division
yeah or watch those watch dogs watch
dogs was the big one 2012 watch dogs i
think it will care about any about any
of that just bring back prince of persia
right bring him back
get him on the road like
that's the series that it might they
might do that i mean they love doing
that thing where they're like they said
there's going to be a new one
but iris the prince of oh i see what
you're saying
it's a new tom clancy yeah exactly this
is a brand new tom clancy tom
of the verb oh brilliant well done
yeah was it the cell park stuff gets
trotted out during ubisoft as well right
yeah fractured butthole the fractured
hole we saw last year probably some more
of that yeah um i mean yeah they've said
that they're going to announce at least
one new ip at e3 or earlier we haven't
seen it yet so presumably then and
there's also a little handful of ubisoft
via virtual reality games that are
getting trotted out eagle flight and
werewolves within as well so eagle
flight is the game where you're just
flying you're a [ __ ] eagle man as an
eagle yeah you're flying and that's it
that's it 15 pounds please
man you don't understand vr you're right
yeah 15 pounds oh 700 for a vr device
how about werewolves within which is
basically a virtual reality game of
hanging out with friends yeah of a game
that you literally can play in real life
in real life
but this one's expensive don't
understand anything apparently it's
really good alexa played uh we're
looking at the eagle flight here uh
alexa i mean every i love the the red
little thing it's like yarny stuck to a
[ __ ] pigeon um but
[Music]
the uh yeah alexa played the werewolves
within apparently had an absolute blast
with it so i mean maybe i can see that
being cool if you're playing with like
random people on the internet that's
weird right to be like vr and then with
random people no i never they don't know
[Music]
you're naked people on the internet
after who knows who that was great you
got to watch people doing like cocaine
in their little xbox live cameras really
oh man you should have that was horrific
oh you should have played uno like three
years after it came out it was dark yeah
the only people playing uno were like
this is this is chat roulette before
chat room yeah totally like fifty fifty
percent chance i clearly missed that one
there you know it was brilliant it was
great so yeah danny what do you think
about vr i mean like usually these
things people quite cynical about it
then they put the helmet on and they're
like oh my god this is amazing and then
i think it's amazing it's just how
amazing is it to get to the sticker
price for it and i mean we're they're
going to get cheaper and cheaper i still
think there's a bunch of amazing games
that have come in the best thing that
i've ever done and it was the oculus
we're getting a little bit sidetracked
here but the oculus touch thing which
was like very much a you know uh
communication experience like a new
version of skype it felt like you know a
paradigm shift it felt like something
that i never would have thought of so
when i see companies like ubisoft who
are making like these like small little
experiences i mean enough of these right
if they talk about wearable for the
[ __ ] fight maybe one or two more little
ones like the more and more games there
are it's like when you buy a console
after a year even though you're not
gonna buy all the games that have been
released the fact that there is this
library is like this comfort blanket
that makes you feel better about
spending four hundred dollars so if
there's enough of these virtual reality
games and if people are and we know sony
are gonna show off a load we know
there's a massive you know they're going
to be showing a lot on the stage for
they're going to show a lot of their
conference you know if games like this
you know werewolves within and and
whatnot they're like interesting little
side notes then enough of those make it
worthwhile they still need their killer
apps so i'm saying these games from
ubisoft they will add to the pile
basically yeah i think so and you know
eventually after a while it becomes you
know a bit more worthwhile so that's
ubisoft i mean watch dogs two we're
definitely going to see assassin's creed
last note on this there's none coming
out this year will we see another one a
really really really smart move to not
yes release another they should like not
engage with assassin's creed this year
right yeah let the movie let fastbender
have his moments
i mean i mean that's the thing that
they're taking a year off but also doing
the movie yeah i mean is that really a
year off right also because they're kind
of breaking the tradition they might
break tradition in the way they reveal
the stuff so it might be that we get a
little teaser logo or something at the
event but then carry on like revealing
it later on down the line is one year
going to be enough are you going to want
assassin's creed again if they if they
that's a good point because i needed two
for watch dogs yeah yeah so yeah perhaps
yeah maybe maybe it will be a little
longer
i hope so because that that franchise i
love but in is in dire need of a reboot
so you both live in las vegas you both
live in london what was your field on
syndicate
i thought it's okay i like the
characters finally like i i haven't
liked very many of the previous two like
edward kenway and connor kenway and
whoever the hell was before that yeah
but these two guys okay yeah these two
guys were all right like
evie and
jacob i think his name is why not sure
yeah like they were cool i like that
london looked nice um but i honestly i
didn't play all the way through it
because yeah i took a different line in
there yeah i was like i couldn't
play it i just right
[Music]
you know fair play to the developers
then they're very talented they do a
great job but
i just can't play another stream
for for a while i think yeah i think
that the kind of like the quick grapple
thing kind of took it out for me like i
like i like the mechanics of jumping and
grabbing and that kind of stuff grow
home yep i know get that in assassin's
creed assassin's creed game over yeah
grow home totally best disaster came
that
certainly last year's bestseller well if
you ask me anyway um yeah grow home is
great i'd love to see more of that or
get that technology into assassin's
creed that'd be absolutely brilliant uh
that's what we think ubisoft's gonna
show off watchdogs too for honor
wildlands a new ip a bunch of vr stuff
maybe a little nod to assassin's creed
and perhaps a prince of persia let us
know what you would like to see in the
comments below and hit that subscribe
button for more e3 rumors here on
gamespot.com rob hello i'm gonna make
you stick around for one more okay
that's fine what are we gonna do we're
gonna the electronic dribble is on next
week
and what would the electronic trip would
be without some electronic artists
crafts that was craftsmen and women who
make sports games
and
and battlefield
and a bunch of other stuff
let's talk about ea actually first of
all let's not talk about their their
staples let's talk about a game that we
haven't seen in a long long time which
we haven't seen much of at all we got a
little bit of a tease of it last year
mass effect andromeda we've actually
seen more of it than ea would probably
like us to see yes that's true
considering that leak recently yeah
recently there was it was like a
graphics
of like just a rogue youtube video of
mass effect andromeda yeah like gameplay
stuff and yeah it looks
i didn't realize how excited i was for
mass effect andromeda until i saw that
that small video clip just just seeing a
krogan again right just like just
i love mass effect i love that universe
i love the characters i love the writing
and
just returning back to that series is
going to be awesome i think i think the
most interesting thing part of it is the
way they're so adamant that they're
cutting ties with the original trilogy
that's what makes me excited it's so
assuring and it gives me confidence in
that yeah they know what they're doing
like a lot of series that go on for this
long they kind of they rely on using
some of the nostalgia and the existing
love yeah franchise or they or they even
connected themselves in a tiny way which
is even too much yeah i think it gives a
war forearm like you don't really need
to have this be marcus phoenix
just like let's let's draw a line in the
sand here yeah i'm afraid to cut the
ties completely totally with this game
andromeda it feels like they're they're
ready to start again start fresh and
you know maybe this is the start of a
brand new trilogy as well yeah
i reckon it definitely will be
considering how successful mass effect
has been so far but like the idea of new
races new planets and kind of like the
technology what it allows us to do now
with i mean they're bringing back
vehicles which is awesome yeah and like
traveling from you know spaceship to on
a planet and
kind of not having any loading times
that kind of stuff this is really
fascinating and even conceptually like
bioware are amazing in creating these
cool ideas like
the pathfinder that's what you are and
before you were the shepherd now you're
the pathfinder and your your whole goal
is to you know find somewhere yeah they
dance with that space opera stuff really
well yeah exactly has a pathfinder thing
being confirmed is that is that
yeah i think it's either it has been
confirmed but
there's so much stuff about like artwork
that has come out with
like you know pathfinder.jpg a hero
that's just that's just gaff messing
with me
i'm doing that yeah and if andromeda is
too wet and i mean i mean it's probably
not coming out anytime soon but in the
meantime you can always check out uh
mary kish and rob handler's sick video
of the mass effect ride yeah which they
went to
a couple of weeks ago 4d it's got all
the d too much d for you to take uh
let's talk about first person shooters
battlefield the first battlefield
tell you what that was a weird week call
of duty infinite warfare came out they
were like whoa we're in space people
were like we're on the opposite side of
space we're in the [ __ ] trenches we
don't even we're not worried about space
right now we're worried about the flu
killing half of
love that they were like oh yeah
infinite warfare and the entire you know
gaming community went ha that's a dumb
name you cannot get a more dumber name
and then yeah we're like battlefield won
i mean we've got an entire series yeah
an entire entire industry was like no
that's fine that's fine yeah that makes
perfect do it done with call of duty so
the fact that like i have never seen a
well okay i have but like in in modern
times in the past couple of years i have
not seen people tear apart a trailer
like they did battlefield one they were
like data mining and there were history
youtube channels which don't talk about
games taking this thing and doing a
piece by piece deconstruction of like
bedouin tribes and you know what the
german soldiers wore and what fronts and
all this sort of stuff i mean i haven't
seen this much hype behind the
battlefield game in a long long time
interestingly those videos that
deconstructed the trailers were
fascinating videos totally yeah and
maybe it's amazing maybe it's because
world war one is inherently really
interesting yeah as a subject matter
something that actually happened totally
sure and it's also one that we don't
it's not like saving private ryan it's
not like band the brothers it's not like
we had grandparents involved you know
what i mean it's it's it doesn't have
that touch like the first world war
feels like an alien thing that happened
and it also was like something that not
a lot of people talk about because quite
frankly it was it was the possibly the
worst warrior it was horrific amounts of
civilian casualties all over the world
redrew the lines of europe and which
have basically not been redrawn much
since because it was such a shocking
event i mean what's going to be
interesting about battlefield 1 is we
know dice are able to make war games but
are they able to make single-player
stories which like do a good job of
touching on what is unbelievably tragic
human event that is the acid test for
them and i don't think they've ever
achieved that when it comes to single
people i know they're a great
multiplayer studio but they haven't
quite done it when it comes to
single-player campaigns battlefield 3
and 4 were sort of the bombastic movie
stuff um most people didn't like them
too much uh i was a decent fan of three
four was kind of fine i mean bad company
was really good but bad company was so
much of a like comedy game it was on the
opposite side i mean there was moments
of sincerity there but something very
interesting i mean ea as a company as a
publisher and developer wider it's it's
kind of filling itself with a lot of
talent that
while not directly related to
battlefield like has a lot of
storytelling chops like they're working
on stuff like star wars and stuff like
that right like they could they could
they could use that talent to bolster
their storytelling abilities somewhat
wherever they do that is you know but
like the thing that's really interesting
is like
the the story of its pitching and like
the way dice had to convince the you
know they're really in charge that this
is something you should be doing and we
had a story recently about you know uh
kind of executive high ups executive
leaving like the worry was
people don't know might not think that
world war one actually happened right so
like the younger youth right now just
totally disconnected
yeah they in the same way that people
believe titanic is a movie right now i
think that actually happened yeah yeah
i'm gonna be really really really
cynical right now but my suspicion
is that the the big heads at ea thought
well titanfall 2 is futuristic yeah
[Music]
we can't have two futuristic first
person war games launching at the same
time against another futuristic war game
precisely yeah so they have to go the
opposite direction so let's talk about
titanfall 2 then uh you know vincent
palette second bite at the cherry that
first game uh respawns first game was a
[Music]
really great little game yeah very
interesting movement mechanics new types
of multiplayer you know there's sort of
two levels of of of battle happening at
the same time uh it did suffer quite a
fall off though in terms of yeah
yeah
six weeks into that a lot of people were
done with it fell off the cliff didn't
it after six weeks and i i was so upset
about that because i mean i got over it
but um
[Music]
but five minutes ago
yeah i was fine after that no it's it's
i thought it was a fantastic game my
goodness um
i thought it was going to be huge i
really thought the one thing people
wanted out of that game the single
player campaign multiplayer you know
perhaps just a
byproduct of a small team trying to make
a big first person shooter but
what do you think about it there's
something about that that just really is
really strange the request because at
the same time this is the team that
create call of duty and the modern call
of duty template as we know it yeah and
everything every time you speak to
someone about call of duty they're like
oh yeah i don't really care about the
campaign i just go straight into
multiplayer well some people do but i
feel like a lot of other people yeah and
over time
less and less like even i i was someone
who started off as a only playing kind
of campaign yeah it was like i'm on
campaign first and then i'll go into
multiplayer now i'm just going straight
into multiplayer but then like titanfall
comes along and it's just a multiplayer
game yes exactly what everyone seemed
like they wanted yeah and everyone's
like where's the single player but you
know why people went straight to the
multiplayer because the campaigns got
[ __ ] yeah true black ops 1 was good call
of duty 4 modern warfare was good modern
warfare 2 was okay black ops 2 was oh
you know and then we got into like the
kevin spacey stuff and then it just
became such an also ran in a game that
had like a solid multiplayer game
there's a really strange contradiction
with uh game sale data which shows that
games that have a single player
component
sell better
than games of just multiplayer but
there's also metrics which show that
when people buy these games they just
play multiplayer
[Music]
yeah so it's like the idea of having
more content like right i feel like
you're getting more or more for your
money up front even if you won't play
like the idea that maybe i'll play the
single player yeah is enough for you to
be like that's true 40 pounds for 40 for
it um i think the titanfall issue for me
wasn't wasn't necessarily single player
it was just like it didn't have enough
content it was almost refined too much
like they had very few like two or three
pistols and by the time you you play
like five or six hours of it and you can
see like the the the top off point on
leveling up unlocking stuff and they
just weren't enough mech variety and
that kind of stuff i think it might be
deeper stuff i think people like stories
they like universes they like to
emotionally invest themselves in these
worlds that they play in and if you just
show them arenas with giant robots and
men jumping around the place yeah that's
nice and women it doesn't grab you in
tight and fall yeah as well which is
yeah the thing is like a lot of that
stuff it once if
as someone who's an anime nerd and you
know love robot
tell me more about how this dude is
summoning a robot from the sky i need to
talk about this it's so cool like and
that's part of it it's a good problem
for them to have yeah people are more
invested than they expected and
obviously these guys are they have grown
exponentially they're working on a star
wars game yes at the same time totally
they've got the team and the money too
you know we haven't had a massive
argument about that didn't we because i
think it's a sign of things not going so
well for them i think it's science like
being like yeah we're on it we've got
this yeah
[Music]
you could cut that one either way yeah
maybe they needed a you know a cushion
in case slightly doesn't work you know i
guess we'll find out um also coming
multi-platform as well so playstation
phones can get their hands on that one
uh let's talk about sports there'll be a
new sports game fifa
sports sports right they'll be a new
[Music]
nhl well we know that that's coming soon
i think they're showing that one off
yeah
frostbite at fifa yeah i mean i mean fox
they they were using pro f was using
bloody
metagasada five true true engine for a
while there um yeah they'll show off all
that stuff i mean there's not much
spring back nba jam for god's sake
they've done that do it again no that
last name again was okay get donald
trump and hillary in there this time
yeah sports games i know they're not
interesting to talk about and i know
they're not trending as sexy topics but
like they're amazingly successful
they're selling they sell an absolute
shock they sell like four or five
million every year can i tell you though
i've bought pez and fifa every year i
haven't played fifa since rocket league
came out yep
so there you go
that's yeah i'm gonna say destroy the
world ssx tricky too okay yeah that
won't be too bad bring it back i guess
let's do this uh let's move on a little
bit here uh hey slice the folks you made
are is it
[Music]
the
brothers a tale of two yeah yeah
yeah they released some sort of game
last year there was a little bit of a
trailer for us they barely showed up it
was like a dev diary which lasted
forever yeah dude on a train yes that
was it it was a dude on a train
hobo simulator 2016. i don't know i am
okay with that yeah so maybe we'll see
that uh we also don't know much about
the sort of the visceral mode of star
wars game uh oh my goodness jade raymond
amy hennig working on you know jade
raymond of of assassin's creed fame
basically herself and desolate made
assassin's creed and you have amy hennig
who is one of the founding uh workers on
the incredible uncharted series bodado's
coming over uh there's word that maybe
they mightn't show much of it but
they'll just do like a paper
announcement so they can get more people
to come to the studio to work on it and
yeah like i don't want to overhype
people but that that the planets have
aligned for that game yeah totally right
like that would be like the greatest
thing and the fact that they got amy
hennig who you know made help make
uncharted and there's this you know
bounty hunter game that lucas canned
that everyone really wants where
[Music]
yeah star wars what was it called seven
seven seventeen seventeen
thirteen thirty yeah that's like i
imagine ea went look everyone's getting
mad over this thing let's grab her and
get to work jade maybe talker took a bit
of a sabbatical from the uh from games
development as well i mean herself and
patrice made one of the most enduring
third person action games in recent
memory so i mean that's really exciting
as well i think it depends how much
freedom disney and lucas arts gives the
lucasfilm gives the team you know if
they give them enough freedom if they
give amy enough freedom to do her own
thing within the star wars universe it
could be could be amazing yeah we'll
have to wait and see uh there you go you
know ubisoft they were showing off some
stuff ea also got a bunch of interesting
things showing off at this year's e3 let
us know which ones you're most excited
about in the comments below and hit that
subscribe button for more e3 rumors
right here on gamespot.com
robert crossley tomorrow saying a
pleasure as ever friends pleasure you
guys go out and write up some more hot
news on it we're going to swap it out
here
we're going to get a bunch of folks you
might know about
one whose face you see a lot on the site
once you name you see a lot on the size
for our last two sections here on what
has been a monster
um
episode of the lobby shout out to
richard lee behind me here with the
steadicam who's been doing it now for 90
minutes how's how you feeling bro
tired he's tired he's tired we're going
to wrap it up pretty soon all right um
mary jean-luc and eric in the back as
well help him put it together uh okay
we're here
we want to talk about video games what
up jess mcdonald how you doing i'm good
how are you wonderful great to have you
here how are you enjoying the bay area i
am enjoying it very much i like san
francisco it's wonderful isn't it it's
nice yeah and here's eddie mccoo nice to
see you good to see you great to be here
the man who makes half of the traffic on
game spot that's not accurate
our new sleuth uh if does anyone have on
about rumors it's you and if it's anyone
better to have on about talking about
the news it's you so uh let's dive
straight into those eddie but i'm gonna
uh let's take into uh two take two uh i
mean some other studios some of the
students underneath them do sort of
announce stuff with um e3 pretty
regularly some of them don't uh so
you're talking about 2k talking about
rockstar you're talking about firaxis um
so let's i guess talk about one of the
main sort of rumors we're seeing at the
moment which is red dead redemption uh a
remastered version of that um eddie
where are we where are these rumors
coming from well what i mean that's
obvious that was one of my favorite
games of the last gen um definitely
something that i'm super looking forward
to the rumors have been pretty shaky at
this point like nothing um official um
[Music]
in addition to the remastered rumors
there's rumors of red dead redemption 2
right that could tie into mafia 3 with
its uh new orleans setting um even
though it's poised to be a prequel
according to the reports um but
everything is looking pretty shaky at
this point and rockstar doesn't
typically announce things at e3 in the
past um they have worked with sony like
uh
[Music]
two years ago to announce gta 5 for
current gen but that one seems
not so solid right yeah i mean gta 5
they did their own live stream thing
right rockstar can do that right
[Music]
time for a new red jess just it just
seems so logical doesn't it i mean it's
still sitting at like number three
backwards compatible like most right
and like
yeah that'd be great i think that'd be
awesome if they're not remastering it
but as a pc gamer i actually missed red
dead right i would love to see it come
to pc there i actually was researching
this earlier today there is just a
subreddit dedicated to please bring red
dead to pc it's interesting i totally
forgot about that whenever i'm looking
for like graphics for like thumbnails
wherever i type red dead redemption in
one of the first things that comes up is
pc and it's literally just form threads
form thirds form
so that's the main thing like i would
love a remastered version because i just
love to see it come to pc yeah i mean i
think you know a sequel would be better
and that's what everyone's really
excited for and then i think if we got
it if we got a sequel it'd be strange if
they not package it with their email
stuff yeah i mean that seems to be the
sort of thing at the moment i think the
other or the other element there too is
we were on a take two earnings call a
couple weeks ago and they've said they
have not modeled in any rockstar
properties for their their current
fiscal year so right i mean that that
doesn't mean it won't get announced or
it might get an i mean but it won't be
out until april 2017 at the very
earliest okay if it does happen that's
not too far away though it could still
happen we've waited we've waited six
years
what's one more uh you talked about it
briefly uh being made actually just
north of here in the bay area mafia iii
uh very interesting game um sort of
interesting uh subject matter
interesting protagonist i mean very much
a big shift uh from what the mafia games
are about predominantly about the mafia
or like taking control of the mafia um
new orleans well wonderful sort of
iconic city to put it on uh what do you
think we're gonna see of this i mean i
feel like they've shown off quite a lot
but there's not that much hyper mafia
three at the moment yeah this one seems
to be kind of flying under the radar and
maybe that's because it hasn't really uh
you know people obviously haven't gotten
hands on yet people don't really know
um they don't have a great grasp for it
yet which i think is why e3 could be a
really big show for it um if they really
emphasize it more and like the setting
you know 1968 um in new orleans with the
protagonist you have the mixed race
character um and then the soundtrack for
me is what i'm really looking for i love
classic rock and it's got you know
painted black house of the rising sun
just like a number of a number of great
songs awesome and one of the great
things about video games especially i
guess open world games is their ability
to transport you to a new place i
remember being in england and ireland
and loving gta because it was like oh
man i'm in i'm in california right you
must feel the same way jess right
division felt like that for me i was
like because i just been to new york for
the first and only time last year and i
was like this is just
okay like a little post-apocalyptic
still very much new york i think like
the setting for mafia 3 does sound
absolutely fascinating i am wondering if
it's going to have
kind of a
the same sort of issue that you guys
were talking about with battlefield 1
where they appear to be dealing with
very heavy subject matters yeah like
they want to talk about like one of the
most racially tense times in like
america's like recent history and it's
like i wonder how that's going to jive
with
mafia gameplay yeah for sure i mean it's
the type of thing you need to sort of do
properly or don't do at all that they're
thinking about it though like i i like
it when games take the leap to try and
like take on a controversial theme as
opposed to you know dealing with things
that are more palatable yeah perhaps
watch dogs 2 doing the same thing as
well we were talking about it earlier
with the creative director too on uh
mafia 3 hayden blackman comes from the
star wars legacy he had an interview or
peter has a great interview on
gamespot.com where they talk about that
um the whole
that time period and they're not just
going there for the sake of going there
they're you know
trying to say something and they're
trying to say it smartly too yeah yeah
let's talk about firaxis civilizations
three sorry six something like that yeah
it's one of those it's one of
uh yeah yeah we're uh that's going to be
i guess we we've i haven't seen much of
that we saw like a trailer right right
and it's coming out in october too which
is very very soon um you know one more
turn people love that franchise i was
just looking up numbers 33 million units
sold throughout the whole franchise
eight million for sip five so i mean
there's a huge install base there people
are definitely interested it's a weird
little sort of it's like strategy games
as well there's like this tiny group of
people well not tiny there's this silent
majority of people who played these
games i was looking at like steam spy
statistics for total warhammer which is
like sold an absolute shetland yeah you
had dave on here before he loves that
series
it sold like i think in a week it had
two weeks on battleborn and sold six
times as many copies um so i mean that's
probably a different story but
uh like that's gonna be incredible
obviously people are very happy to see
more of civ six especially some actual
gameplay since all we saw was the sort
of stylistic trailer you're looking at
now um let's talk about another one
which may or may not be on the table for
uh for 2k and take two uh ken levine's
new game what is he working on you're on
that side of the world yeah so he's out
in boston that's right around where i am
too and he's been talking about how his
this game's gonna have a semi-open world
which i mean he just talks in all these
kind of vague terms but if there's
anyone if there's anyone you can trust i
would you know to pull off a vision you
know he has he has the pedigree he has
the history of bioshock everybody loves
that obviously um but unfortunately we
really don't know much about it but e3
you know could be
a place where they start to talk about
it thrown around some odd ways of
describing this game right like saying
people don't really want the bioshock
type like really story heavy linear
linear experience anymore which i don't
really agree with i love that kind of
experience but he said like he really
wants to focus on replayability and
stuff right but he says that he's like i
really wanted to be replayable but we
still need to really make a story game
when we really care about story yeah and
it's also open world and it's also open
world and he's called it like he's it's
like we're gonna have narrative puzzle
pieces so you can work them together in
different ways so then it's like is that
making choices or is that i i don't know
yeah
and we also don't like know too much
about the team he's working with i know
when you know when a rational split up
he said there were it was him and like a
handful like a small group of people
that you know stayed on so what is the
scale here um is he bringing on outside
people to work with i mean there's a lot
of unanswered questions yeah hopefully
we'll see some uh i see some of them
answered at e3 uh let's also talk about
gearbox i mean battleborn has not worked
out like it's sold 150 000 on pc or
something
yeah i mean bad timing and overwatch you
got to say but also just didn't really
grasp people's attention i mean it's the
concurrent viewer concurrent player
numbers at the moment which are like
floating against steam spy but it looks
like it's rained like 2000 a day like
1500 a day it's pretty poor it is and uh
well it seems that way i mean we were on
that same take two earnings call and the
the ceo was saying that um it's too soon
to say because there were some uh
comments uh from i think the creative
director randy varnell who said it's off
to a pretty decent start which is kind
of what uh borderlands had and
borderlands was kind of a slow burner
back in the day so it it didn't it
didn't start off as this you know giant
meg hit but over time it became that and
he said you know okay what's good
we might be on that path but it's it's
too soon to say at this point but the
one kind of redeeming thing about it
potentially is they said at a pax seas
panel that um
it's uh dlc is gonna have hints at
borderlands three so people might play
it for that reason there you go i mean
yeah like a new borderlands is pretty
likely um maybe some you know yeah that
extra battle born dlc we'll see i i was
entering interviewing randy pitchford
ash i forget where it was i think it
might have been pax last year and
the i talked to my brother in arms
brothers and arms and he said very much
that they were going to get back into it
like you know and it seemed like he
wanted to do it pretty soon and that
could be another i mean i'd love to see
another one of those hell's highway is a
fantastic game when they came out with
what was it 2013 or 28 i forget what
year was when they had the uh brothers
in arms um the furious four right uh the
quentin tarantino kind of inspired over
the top killing nazis things like that i
was kind of i was kind of into that hook
um but they you know they scuttled that
and they said we're gonna you know kind
of reboot that could come back with
something new and they haven't really
given much about that but that's
definitely that's definitely one of the
games that i'm looking forward to it was
my team that worked on a couple of games
so i'm sure they've got a couple down
their sleeves uh any fans of evolve
at the table
i actually we went in to play evolve
right before it came out uh me
dan hines who used to work here uh zarin
and ed
and we had the best time right it was us
and like my good friend from cnet
against like other games journals and it
was so much fun like being able to like
fill certain roles and stuff and like it
relies so heavily on you working
together yeah just like being a good
team communication you can't just be a
good player you have to be a good team
and i think there were really promising
elements there that just didn't end up
working together and it also just it
always felt like the same match in the
same game
which was probably you know something
that overwatch isn't running into
because there's just so many different
shoes you can fill and different ways
you can approach it and it's a
completely different game depending on
the heroes
um i i still think about two is going to
happen i would be surprised if they were
like i wonder how like how did it sell
like chris waters feels the same way as
you and i remember mary and a couple of
folks in the office here really enjoy
playing together just unlike left 4 dead
2 in which you could play with random
people and have a fun time it just it
was so irritating and the games were so
long it sold multiple millions copies it
did it did really it did and the
potentially more unbelievable thing is
strauss zellner the ceo of take two had
called it a permanent franchise along
with red dead and uh gta so it's
something that happened to and they've
also said well he suggested that the
first game might have been too
multiplayer centric and he wanted to put
in a little more single player in the
next one just a little more exposition
for the story and where you are and
things like that sweet concept i mean
like
being like with a little crew and taking
on a huge like
you know
pissed off monster picture of straight
cell neck holy crap
i mean it's it's just a shame it's one
of those things that was just a really
cool idea and it's yeah a real pity you
know what turtle rock probably deserve a
second bite at that cherry anyway so we
wouldn't take it away from them uh and
then last thing i guess to talk about
would take two is
question mark question from our question
mark new rockstar ip
it could happen it could happen i mean
if you don't if yeah we're just going to
say agents so they renewed that
trademark fairly recently but that
doesn't necessarily mean anything
they're just you know holding their
rights over it um
but uh which doesn't cost them any money
right right and and it creates another
news cycle around it yeah
[Music]
yeah exactly good for you guys
i think people are just going to be mad
bummed if they don't see red dead
everyone just wants to see red dead too
quick for a new gta at this stage
they've said they're working on a
rockstar has multiple unannounced new ip
in development um and they haven't even
teased up anything about that i mean a
rockstar is usually very very
tight-lipped about those kind of things
and they make their own announcements um
yeah and e3 is not typically the stage
for rockstar but i mean anything can
like anything's possible new warriors
new bully a new bully would be great i
believe would be excellent yeah you know
set in a new england boarding school so
i can relate i didn't go to boring
school but
i grew up in new england yeah that'd be
good stuff uh there you go that's all
the take two and it's very many
subsidiaries have maybe up their sleeves
let us know let us know what you think
uh they're gonna answer what you'd like
to see in the comments below and hit
that subscribe button for more of our
hot rumors
we're almost done
it's a rally richard lee behind me
almost collapsing he's doing a great job
great job buddy i've been standing the
whole time yeah yeah yeah he's
incredible that's good
i love it when we're when we're getting
semi-transparent straws on the on the
screen we know that the guys in the back
are getting a bit weary
so let's wrap this one up
e3
big stage for people to announce video
games uh one of the biggest queer
publishers in the world of video games
is activision so let's talk about what
they may or may not be showing off let's
talk about what they may be showing off
first call of duty infinite warfare i'm
guessing we're gonna see that just
probably see it yeah um eddie and i were
just talking about it and obviously you
know we've always got battlefield versus
call of duty yeah and i i think it's
it's really funny just how
sort of disconnect between the people
who make games the people who play games
like you guys already talked about it
like how worried ea are that like you
know the historical setting is not
something that gamers want to see and
then it was exactly what gamers us yeah
but i think you know obviously they're
just really aware of the fact that call
of duty is doing sci-fi and they've got
the future and it's interesting to me
there is call of duty fatigue which i
think is contributed to how much people
are hating on that that announcement and
that yeah and there is just like a
there's a mob who's out for cod in a way
oh they absolutely are but it's kind of
like the thing is at the end of the day
they can make a really great game they
have to take advantage of that setting
though
and they have to take advantage of the
stuff that ea is afraid of which is you
can do cool [ __ ] with the future that
there that battlefield are not going to
be able to do
don't get me wrong all the world war one
stuff is going to be amazing that's
going to be a really cool setting but
you know if if they get the right team
together if they have the right like
creative vision they can come up with
like brand new combat mechanics and all
kinds of [ __ ] that's going to be awesome
i mean contemporary war stories were
never good for the longest time and then
call of duty 4 came out like with the
right people on it you can get it done
and speaking of that they have had
they've actually hired after the big
exodus at infinity ward um they hired
some naughty dog people who came in who
are going to be writing the story which
is you know exciting to to think about
we don't know how it's going to be
executed yet yeah but that's definitely
one of the things i'm looking forward to
and then
just you know battle uh space dog fights
i mean you've never been able to do that
really in call of duty which is which
seems really exciting too and there's
going to be maps on different planets i
mean yeah and if jess says like as she
said like if you take advantage of that
if you have like 0g gunfights which are
weird and like yeah just like if you if
you just say like
it's a first-person shooter with the
trappings of space it's probably not
going to be it needs to be more than
caught in space that's it it needs to
like really own this concept yeah so how
are sales going for call of duty because
like it's so hard to tell right because
we seem to be selling really well every
year we're hearing that there's this
plateau and a dip in recent years is
that the case it's tricky because the
black ops series is typically their
number one franchise overall so i mean
there's there's you know peaks and
valleys every time they come out um
but uh you know infinity ward is
obviously one of the most uh
you know one of the most respected and
they created modern warfare obviously so
you know there are high hopes for this
one certainly and it's the first one you
know as of yet they haven't announced uh
support for last gen consoles too so we
don't know right if that could you know
free them up to do more things that you
know if they didn't have to think about
last gen too so fingers crossed right
yeah um let's jump into uh another big
game for them world of warcraft uh
legion
that's the thing that's coming out that
is a thing any wow players here i used
to play wow i played wow a lot but you
know not not recently you know i usually
get drawn back when the expansions come
out i don't know if it'll be the case
this time oh really um but i'm
definitely i mean i'm looking forward to
it um there's there's a chance that i'll
go back i mean in terms of subscriber
numbers though um every time there's a
dip
right before every new expansion comes
out and right now they are at a nine
year low so they really need this one to
you know kick in and really bring more
people like myself back everyone i know
who plays well plays it in waves like
they pick it up for a month or two
comes out and then
subscription is cancelled again when
they remember to cancel it
yeah exactly yeah maybe they got to push
off the movie i don't know it's been
getting weird reviews at the moment yeah
there's a promotion going on too where
certain theaters will give you the game
and all the expansions if you go buy a
movie ticket so yeah what what
all of the expansions well all the
expansions now are actually free as of
like a couple weeks ago
yeah really so you got it
they want people back in right yeah yeah
god i'd be so butthurt if i like bought
them all in anticipation
yeah when you think about like
i mean it's still obviously the number
one paid mmo on the market no one's even
close yeah it's you know they're the
genre defining mmo they've been out for
10 years um but it is seems like we're
at a point of crossroads here yeah yeah
uh let's talk about uh one of their more
successful new uh jaunts into the world
of multiplayer gaming destiny uh rise of
iron is a
rumor we have seen we've seen pretty
decent like screenshot images which are
sorry of i guess media you know
promotional it's not actual gameplay um
do you think we're going to see that
this year i mean presumably they've
talked about how they expect the falloff
and bungie say that whenever we release
the new one of these it gets them all
back on that's the most important thing
there's going to be an announcement
event this coming thursday um where
they're going to talk about it uh we're
going to talk about what's next for
destiny which the big you know the
obviously uh the point is to uh rise of
iron um
but whether or not i mean and they've
said that uh or the rumor is that it's
going to be larger more substantial than
house of wolves and
um the previous expansion of the dark
below so there's there's a lot riding on
it though too cool i wonder if that's
paving the way for them to do destiny 2
at e3 my original thought is that it's
too soon because they're gonna want all
the focus to be on their you know
massive latest expansion and people
picking that up not thinking about the
next game yeah for sure but the fact
that they're announcing it in advance
and we're probably going to hear a lot
about the next expansion on thursday
they haven't said it's going to be the
next expansion but it's a good guess
but yeah i wonder what they're going to
pull out at e3 it seems like a strange
time to decide to talk about it yeah
just ahead of e3 you're right though
there has to be a reason right yeah if
that's the reason that that seems like
an odd reason because either they're not
really going to say anything so they can
say more at e3 in which case why hold it
on thursday
or they're doing it so then they can do
a little destiny 2 teaser or something
what if they just go well into it what
if on thursday just announced destiny
for pc oh gosh yes i mean they have like
eric hershberg the ceo of activision
publishing was in an interview and he
said you know destiny is a good fit on
paper for pc you know everything sets up
well it's just and i don't know why they
wouldn't do it i mean all the other
franchises are there most of them it's
weird yeah yeah it's only yeah it's one
of these things you kind of forget about
oh yeah
like red dead yeah you think it's such
an obvious fit so why wouldn't they do
it if you say it enough it you know
it'll happen
yeah we've been saying read that for a
while
let's look at i mean looking at the rest
of activation's ips it is a
a big list of of
of if spots and maybes i mean i can't
see no tony hawk getting done i'm
curious to know about what might happen
with guitar hero right they've said
sales have fallen like they were below
what they wanted which it like it's not
necessarily a death knell for it because
maybe they had you know predicted too
high um but at the same time i've been
playing the new guitar hero and the new
guitar is you know it quite a
leap from what it was and it's not as
easy to get into which i thought was the
whole appeal of guitar hero was that
anybody can pick up and play
a living room rock star but it's kind of
tricky this time i feel like it's also
we grew up with like that kind of guitar
like that i'm easter and it's just like
getting used to buttons that are next to
each other and then down the front is
like wow are we too are we old dogs with
new tricks already gosh that's just
surprising we're just old that's the
problem what about skylanders i mean
disney infinity's fallen by the wayside
that space got real busy
i mean i think it has to help right
because like
i mean with all the different players
that were in there that market just
didn't grow big enough to to you know
accommodate them all and some something
had to give i guess it wasn't enough for
disney yeah do you think they're going
to keep going with skylanders
[Music]
store and they have see chris waters i
always say i hear him like i know he's
there and yet it still it surprises me
it's always not every time like santa
claus
but i i mean i
sorry
i'm not counting that out i mean
obviously uh you know randy is a big
skylanders fan himself and he always
talks about how uh you know that
franchise has more appeal than maybe
people are you know talking about it i
mean it's uh
something that that i wouldn't bet
against yeah there you go well anything
else you can think of activation wise
activision is just going to do
activision activations well they don't
have a booth at e3 this year which is
interesting
[Music]
and david said you know elected to
partner with sony for call of duty um
whether or not it shows up at their
booth or you know presumably it'll be at
their um
stage show yeah on monday all right well
we'll have to wait and see not too much
longer though tick tock e3 is a comment
make sure you check out gamespot for all
the latest e3 news throughout the week
we've also got two crazy stage shows
downstairs we've got the co-op stage
with our friends at screw attack and
kind of funny live and look at this
lovely picture it's just appearing on my
favorite god oh my it's my annual
check-in with dr bobby looking forward
to that um yeah we've got a great state
show downstairs a wonderful trailer rob
handler put together up on the site and
on youtube as well i'm pretty sure by
this stage uh and then upstairs we were
doing game demos for three days straight
myself jess and lucy are going to be a
man in that one um so that'll be great
we've also got a wonderful set of
interviews with various developers uh
which should be great to listen into so
make sure you check that out thank you
so much to richard lee for holding on to
that goddamn steadicam for almost two
hours monster podcast today produced by
mary kish in the back jean-luc psyche
eric tay and a bunch of other people
thank you so much all of our guests for
coming on today including you wonderful
international slash east coast folk
thank you danny much obliged and thank
you for listening on your podcast
machines we will not be here next week
electronic triple is happening there
won't be nothing on this feed
either so if you want to check out some
of the stuff that's going on at e3 via
gamespot make sure you go to
gamespot.com or youtube.com forward
slash gamespot we're also streaming all
next week so make sure you hit that
subscribe button all right let's get out
of here we got a truck to pack up adios
see you in two weeks time here in the
lobby see you next week for the biggest
week in video games take care see you
then
you